we might be drunk
we might be drunk
as long as we are hanging out you know
we might be drunk raise a glass let's
talk [ __ ] head peeps wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk
we might be drunk
yeah
hey folks here we are the patreon the
real fans the real drunks the real
boozlers i like that elaine boos that's
gonna stick i hope so because you know
drunks is so basic this is a little
interesting
yeah problematicos
i don't know what we're going to do but
hey we love you guys we appreciate you
quick shout out to the great uh late
great louis anderson we go into more
detail how much we like him in a later
episode but we just want to quickly say
man
uh comedy grape so oh yes sorry pig
watch his
carson set it made his career it was
like a breakout set and then he did a
killer ferguson you said oh he did like
10 ferguson's really yeah yeah no it's
like crazy to think about guys at that
age don't keep doing like late night
sets yeah they do panel he kept doing
sets so it's like the dude knew how to
structure an act
very funny guy very funny panel are you
ever interested in panel i think it
would be so much more fun than stand up
really
lower pressure if you say something
funny on panel you're
you're in the same seat actors are in
ah good point you're doing stand up
every line better be a [ __ ] home run
good point i mean bill burr's panel
there's not much better than that but
again he had conan though
because billboard was on conan kill and
conan got it conan would feed him and
then he did colbert at once and it was a
little awkward
yeah colbert doesn't get comics like us
no no no he's into like weird comics
he's like he's like you better be like
coming out with like a like a cat
playing with string or some [ __ ] exactly
he doesn't want to hear like
joke jokes yeah yeah
burr is like saying crazy [ __ ] i also
just feel like colbert is very much like
like conan knew how to like even if he
disagreed with you he knew how to roll
with it yes
like conan would kind of be like what
did you just say and that keeps it going
because you're kind of
even if you don't agree with it you it's
like a volley yeah exactly yeah like
norm wouldn't be great on a lot of
people like what are you talking about
you psycho but kona would play with it
yeah he would be smiling the whole time
colberto would almost be like he's
protecting his neck
yes exactly which is not great comedy no
we want to be out on the on the
tight wire
now conan is a master straight man
because it's like man who doesn't have a
straight man who could just take over
and be the funniest person at any second
so yeah good point
dude love conan what do what is that
there matt what do we what do we have up
there we did a poll on patreon for what
we should name
oh
the enablers that's pretty good
so barrett's get out of here drunkarino
regulars was a write-in request too that
did pretty well
okay
yeah they're regulars that's not bad
like a bar he's a regular yeah enablers
is pretty good
yeah that's not bad
all right good job folks
okay let's go to some questions you guys
sent us questions at
we might be drunk pod at gmail
let's go over some of them uh
munzer hodeifer
[ __ ] sam it's a rick and morty
question which one of the
interdimensional cable tv shows is your
favorite i don't remember i i know the
show i'm trying to think of like
you got a list of those yeah are there
are there lists i don't off the top of
my head i don't have it that's the
beauty of the internet
all right all right
oh this these are going to be because
these are great because they're jokes in
themselves
just the names of tv shows and whatnot
but uh oh you can't go to video
i don't know dude i think we might have
to go to another question this is might
be too inside even for us yeah take this
[ __ ] over to reddit will you what do you
think this is huh uh comic-con we don't
know that stuff
gage hamilton that's a porn star if i've
ever heard one page gage hamilton jesus
my name is gage all right what leather
jacket are you wearing right now gage
yeah right
cool bracelet yes that's what they call
those hoops you know those earrings that
have a hole
a game that's a gauge yeah what do you
do i don't mean to sound old-fashioned
here but what are you doing easy
cardigan
[Laughter]
i agree it's silly it's you're ruining
your ears
you only got one
although i can tell progress because i
saw a trans person the other day and the
trans person was pierced here and i was
like what's with the piercing
so that's progress right that's
something yeah and
the problem with those those loops
though is they you take them out and the
ears dangling like an old pair of
florida tits you know it's like a
six-year-old man's balls yes for years
it's it's funny to think that in old
folks homes in like when we're old it's
going to be like an old lady with a
tattoo on her tits uh the gauges weird
piercing holes back uh [ __ ] stamps in
the old folks home yeah nothing good
about a drooping
uh [ __ ] stamp there
yeah
yeah very good where are you at on tats
i'm not a fan
i i mean i'm against them if like look
if if it works it works but like
i don't know it's i wouldn't get one i
don't think i well i wouldn't get one
either but i feel bad because i wouldn't
want my girlfriend or wife to have a ton
but i've had sex with gals who are
covered in them and that's fun yeah a
little vacation it's a vacation yeah
exactly you don't want to live there but
you take a little trip right
stamp lane yes sure that way this is
[ __ ] your sober [ __ ] [ __ ] you so far
how many felonies you got oh this guy's
hammer felonies
at first if i had them i don't think i'd
uh admit them live on a podcast yeah
that's true but is he saying to is he
talking to sober people or are we the
sober [ __ ] i'm confused
i don't i mean matt peters what do you
think
i don't know because we're obviously
drinking in every episode almost i think
this guy is drunk i think he wrote it
too [ __ ] you sober [ __ ] maybe we're not
drinking enough in the episodes yeah
according to him i'm surprised he got
the uh
the the typos out like he got the words
the spelling right for a shit-faced guy